bonjour vous allez bien on va commencer
par un dialogue constant pinkham arrivé
du cameroun il ya dix ans donne le
dernier cours de français avant les
fêtes à une dizaine d'employés chez
peerless manquements les e-menaces le
clan on leur apprend à être capable à
fonctionner dans la société
la langue d'état l'outil de
communication privilégié on l'a
apprendre les rudiments poète
fonctionnaires c'est fini les peaux
c'est mario ayala arrivé ici il ya 30
ans comme réfugiés salvadorien qui a
poussé pour que des cours de français
soit donnée dans l'entreprise c'est très
important parce que la plupart d
ailleurs ici on était six migrants
quatre chars n 15 pour ça n'a pas pris
alors beaucoup on a des difficultés à
s'exprimer
ça c'est moche qu'est ce qu'il me semble
touche les plus parce que moi je veux
que ces problèmes là puis mais ces cours
n'aurait jamais eu lieu son engagement
des patrons de peerless et l'aide du
ministère de l'immigration qui les
finances de l'entreprise
ça leur permet d'avoir un lieu de
travail est un lieu de formation à la
fois pour lui arsenault la francisation
en entreprise est la clé du succès les
gens sont fiers ça crée un sentiment
d'appartenance à l'entreprise et
maintenance est même perçue comme un
avantage
on le voit chez nos nouveaux employés
qui sont déjà au courant qu on offre des
cours de français
pourtant si l'on se fie aux chiffres
fournis par la fédération des chambres
de commerce du québec seulement 240
entreprises sur un total de 258 mille se
prévalent de ce type de formation ça
prend un bassin important demandeur
il est en détention de caen mai 1950
employés dans les usines
ça nous permet d'avoir suffisamment de
deux personnes les individus intéressés
à suivre des cours de français
les données sont toutefois éloquente 700
mille travailleurs au québec sont nés à
l'étranger comme de kondengui barras qui
a suivi tous les cours de français chez
pioneer avec sa quille a pris ici je
vous allez maintenant 110 enfants afin
de mieux accompagner je peux aller au
gouvernement j'ai pu aller porter ou à
l'hôpital
remplir n'importe quel document sur le
plan on va choisir quatre choses 14 joie
et on va aider l'autre ça prend clichy
recours parce que l'effet de les avoir
quatre heures par semaine puis des fois
il peut pas se présenter parce qu'ils
sont fatigués ça prend un peu plus de
temps c'est un peu plus difficile mais
ça fonctionne la vérificatrice générale
du québec avait déploré l'an dernier des
lacunes importantes dans les programmes
gouvernementaux de francisation
les réformes se font toujours attendre
qu'est ce qu'on va faire ici catherine
kovacs radio-canada à montréal